it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the stories
behind the headlines so that we turn to
the author of the wise men who found
Christmas out now and Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo all right
Raymond Biden is spinning spinning the
Blarney again Laura nearly every Biden
event or interview could really be
billed as Story Time with Grandpa Joe at
a fireman's event yesterday this was the
tail spun literally literally
lightning struck a little Pond behind my
house came up through the ground into
the air conditioning system ended up
generating thick black smoke literally
literally that of those proportions and
from the basement to the third floor the
attic everything was ruined and the
kitchen floor we almost lost a couple
firefighters they tell me
they who who told you the truth is it
was a small kitchen fire Laura that was
out in 20 minutes we have the the
article well as my granddad told me Joey
when you got a fire extinguisher handy
don't forget to pull the pin like if she
says anything
but the stories and shifts in identity
he has been a coal miner's grandson an
arrested civil rights activist none of
which is true none of this is new by the
way a few weeks ago Biden tried to pass
himself off as being raised in the
Puerto Rican community of Delaware when
he was taking time off from being Jewish
I probably uh went to shul more than
many of you did Saturday and on Sunday
you all think I'm kidding I'm not anyone
who constantly has to add I'm not
kidding no joke this is a God's honest
truth is probably not telling the God's
honest truth and it erodes confidence in
everything he says Lord that's the
problem well Raymond they're they're his
verbal crutches like if he forgets where
he is in a sentence he always says Ah I
don't have time I don't want to I don't
want to get into that right now because
he forgets where he is on the list of
things he's talking about all right well
today Biden told this Whopper in
Colorado oh I say this is a father of a
man who won the broad star the
conspicuous service medal and lost his
life in Iraq
that is so sad I mean Bo Biden did not
die in Iraq he died in 2015 of brain
cancer at home so again the conflation
and the expansion of these stories Laura
even the New York Times finally getting
wise they acknowledged that Biden spins
Yarns that often unravel we might call
that pandering and lying but
we're not are you sure he was talking
about his son there Raymond was he
talking about someone else he was
talking about Bo he said as the father
of a son who who died in Iraq
when did that happen well the kicker
though is after he's called out by the
New York Times he then goes on with Jake
Tapper to talk climate change and then
he just starts throwing out numbers you
know forget about the facts
we passed 368 billion dollars worth of
help which as the same Bankers talk
about that's going to bring up billions
a trillions 700 million dollar billion
dollars off the sidelines investment
billion trillion quadrillion zillion
every time he talks about numbers Laura
he sounds like an Auctioneer you know
give me a billion give me two billion
what I found curious was Jake Tapper he
books the president of the United States
gives him 15 minutes then he gives the
rock nearly the same amount of time but
maybe it makes sense he had to explore
the Deep political message of The Rock's
new Black Adam superhero movie
there's also this theme about how
westerners have no right to impose their
views or decisions on conduct there
isn't an anti-imperialism
anti-colonialism theme that I've never
seen before in a superhero movie
well thank you for pointing that out
thematically I feel like we tried to add
as many layers as possible why do we
care about the back story of this
superhero who goes to a superhero movie
to get a political message
Anti-Imperialist anti-colonialist this
was about pushing the rock to run for
president Laura and he took a pass for
now at least
Raymond looks like Jake is he trying to
do like the Larry King thing or I'm not
quite sure that no tie yeah they open
kind of a relaxed look yeah yeah it's
kind of an endearing thing I guess but
do you think he gave Joe 15 or was he
supposed to give Joe an hour and then
they had to cut it because Joe was
getting very likely very lost yeah all
right well before I let you go Raymond
your picture book the wise men who found
Christmas is just out just came out this
week tell us a little bit about the book
The Toilet we're just about to hit the
road this is the true story of the wise
men they were not Kings they were not
from the Far East that's all a legend
and there may have been more than three
of them and the historic reality of
their Journey where it started in Arabia
turns out to be a high stakes adventure
and I've kind of assembled what I
learned for the whole family and when
you bring the Magi into Focus the one
they sought the Christ child suddenly
becomes more real as well I'm going to
be at the Reagan Library next week in La
at the Grove I've got a virtual signing
tomorrow borrow all the details at
Raymond arroyo.com I hope you'll get a
copy and I hope you'll come see me and
Laura I think you're joining me on a
couple of these clandestine visits as we
go when they you never that's an
interesting book tour when it's
clandestine all right Raymond I'll show
up you know I will well yeah exactly I'm
congratulations that's awesome hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else